وجبه الديك الرومي الرئيسي في عشاء عيد
الميلاد البريطانيه التقليدي في خطر هذا
ما حذر منه القائمون على الصناعه الدواجن
بسبب انفلونزا الطيور في افاده امام لجنه
البيئه والغذاء والشؤون الريفيه بالبرلمان
هذا الموسم
لانفلونزا الطيور ومنذ بدايه اكتوبر
140 حاله مقارنه باعداد محدوده في السنوات
القليله الماضيه
انفلونزا الطيور
بشكل مباشر او غير مباشره
انتاج الديوك خارج الحظائر التي يقدر
تعدادها بمليون و300 الف جنيه كونها
الاكثر عرضه للاصابه بالانفلونزا مقرره
بتلك التي تعتمد على الانتاج المكثف في
الاماكن المغلقه
سنضطر الى قتل القطيع باكمله بمجرد تاكيد
حاله ايجابيه وهذا يعني خساره المبيعات
وكمرب للديوك يجب ان لا نخجل الناس في
اعياد الميلاد هذا وضع المدمر
بحسب مجلس الدواجن فان اجماليه
لعيد الميلاد في بريطانيا يصل الى تسعه
ملايين طائر ويخضع 36 في المئه من منتجها
لقيود صارمه بسبب الانفلونزا فيما لا يعرف
بعد ما اذا سيتم تعويض نقص المحتمل من دول
اخرى مع اتلاف قطعان باكملها دفعت مربيها
على حافه الافلاس
في ما يطالب المتضررون بمراجعه شامله
لنظام التعويضات الخاص بانفلونزا الطيور
يزدادوا قلقه مربي الدواجن من احتمال
التاثر امدادات الديك الرومي في عيد
الميلاد ومن مدى قدره الناس على تامين
كلفه هذه الوجبه التقليديه في حاله تعويض
النقص عبر الاستيراد وسط ازمه غلاء معيشه
استثنائيه مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن